I'm Baba Booey oh here's the puppet hey
Fred I was thinking see we can use the
Gary puppet just leave it by Fred let
him work it Kasey's get a bag this is
such a beautiful puppet it's like a
homeless dummy hello am I on TV right
now oh good
hey both I have to pick my nose oops
that's my ear
somebody just faxed me that Gary always
looks befuddled on the easy I know
doesn't he
that's the same look I see Fred and
Jackie look the same way you just don't
see them pull so Fred I was just
thinking that like if you know you're
ever good friend Gary and you do Gary's
voice you know hey both hey both you
could have the puppet it's real easy to
work - I gotta go is fiddling with it
yesterday it's easy but Howard it's
gonna be really difficult because when
Fred does is impersonation of me he
needs to keep a pen in his mouth and
around can you do it without that pen
I'll try and do it with a cart in my
mouth all right it's kind of a neat
little puppet and here Fred I'll hand
over the puppet as long as the arms
almost hit the floor his arms his hands
go past his knees I like what he's
wearing - he's usually wearing a bad
t-shirt that works for something's -
nice yeah yeah that's Gary let me tell
you something I've never worn bad jeans
like that and cuffed them I just like to
say that right all bad jeans like that
was good you're a little too clear do it
again let me see if I can do this Oh
Fred stuffing papers right Gary a little
ear wax on what you what do you think
excellent oh you do look befuddled Baba
Booey okay make me spin his head around
for a pretty good ventriloquist
no you just hardly see the piece of
paper
having say this hey wolf which is my
good side my left tooth on my right
tooth which is my good side my left
tooth
oh my Rob - excellent and look how it's
always I think the teeth are too white
yeah
the Gary puppet is green on his teeth
yeah I wouldn't say it has to be green
but it might need a little temptation be
discolored yeah a hint of mint mob day
brush my teeth I get a Gary puppet he's
busy hey Gary puppet oh you just took a
shot to the head produces the Gary
puppet is a bat when your teeth are like
a shield
they should be guarding I like when Gary
holds the Gary puppet next to his face
yeah hold it next hand open your mouth
like the puppet I put them right next to
your head oh my head
I'll smell what's the matter why can't
you put him next year all right put his
hand there Tony hang your lower lip hold
that just hold it for a while I gotta
soak that in tell Gary is the area good
Gary's the one with the earring gotta
get the pop at the earring then we won't
be able to tell the difference
here's what I think you will look wrong
finger mr. Gary puppet wrong finger
again puppet only has four fingers all
right thank you Gary puppet